y necesitamos recuperar nuestros vínculos:
también ese duro juicio
que llevo en el corazón contra mi hermano o mi hermana,
esa herida no curada, ese mal no perdonado,
ese rencor que solo me hará daño,
es un pedacito de guerra que llevo dentro,
un foco en el corazón que debe extinguirse
para que no desate un incendio y no deje cenizas.
Muchos hoy, por diversos motivos,
no parecen creer que sea posible un futuro feliz.
Estos temores se toman en serio.
Pero no son invencibles.
Se pueden superar,
si no nos cerramos en nosotros mismos.
Porque la felicidad solo se experimenta
como el don de armonía de cada uno con el todo.
También las ciencias - lo saben mejor que yo -
nos indican hoy una comprensión de la realidad,
donde cada cosa existe en relación, en interacción continua con las otras.
Esto me lleva a mi segundo mensaje.
Qué maravilloso sería
si el aumento de las innovaciones científicas y tecnológicas
correspondiese también con una mayor equidad e inclusión social.
Qué maravilloso sería si, mientras descubrimos nuevos planetas,
descubriésemos las necesidades del hermano y la hermana que orbitan a mi alrededor.
Qué maravilloso sería que la fraternidad,
esta palabra tan bonita y a veces incómoda,
no se redujese solo a la asistencia social,
sino que se convirtiese en la actitud básica
en las decisiones a nivel político, económico, científico,
y en las relaciones entre personas, entre pueblos, y países.
Solo la educación en fraternidad, en una solidaridad concreta,
puede superar la "cultura del descarte",
que no trata solo de alimentos y bienes,
sino ante todo de personas
marginadas de sistemas tecno-económicos,
en cuyo centro, sin percatarse,
a menudo ya no está más el hombre, sino los productos del hombre.
La solidaridad es una palabra
que muchos quieren quitar del diccionario.
Sin embargo, la solidaridad no es un mecanismo automático,
no se puede planificar o controlar:
es una respuesta libre que nace del corazón de cada uno.
Sí, ¡una respuesta libre!
Si uno entiende que su vida
aunque en medio de tantas contradicciones,
es un don,
que el amor es la fuente y el sentido de la vida,
¿cómo puede contener el deseo de hacer el bien a los otros?
Para participar activamente en el bien
hace falta memoria, hace falta coraje, y también creatividad.
Me han dicho que en TED
se reúne mucha gente muy creativa.
Sí,
el amor pide una respuesta creativa, concreta, ingeniosa.
No bastan los buenos propósitos y las fórmulas ya consagradas,
que a menudo solo sirven para tranquilizar conciencias.
Juntos, ayudémonos a recordar
que el otro no es una estadísticas o un número:
el otro tiene un rostro,
el "tú" es siempre un rostro concreto,
un hermano al que cuidar.
Hay una historia que contó Jesús
para explicar la diferencia
entre quien no se preocupa
y quien cuida del otro.
Probablemente la conozcan, es la parábola del Buen Samaritano.
Cuando preguntaron a Jesús: "¿quién es mi prójimo?"
- es decir, ¿a quién debo cuidar? -
Jesús contó esta historia,
la historia de un hombre al que los ladrones habían asaltado,
robado, golpeado y abandonado en el camino.
Dos personas muy respetables de la época, un sacerdote y un levita
lo vieron,
pero pasaron de largo sin pararse.
Después llegó un samaritano, que pertenecía a una etnia despreciada,
y este samaritano al ver a ese hombre herido en el suelo,
no pasó de largo como los demás, como si no pasara nada,
sino que tuvo compasión.
Se conmovió y esta compasión
lo llevó a actuar de manera muy concreta:
vertió aceite y vino sobre las heridas de aquel hombre,
lo llevó a un albergue
y pagó de su bolsillo los cuidados necesarios.
La historia del Buen Samaritano es la historia de la humanidad de hoy.
En el camino de los pueblos hay heridas provocadas por el hecho
de que en el centro está el dinero, están las cosas.
No las personas.
A menudo es costumbre de quienes se creen respetables
no cuidar de los otros,
dejando a tantos seres humanos,
pueblos enteros, atrás, tirados por el camino.
Existe sin embargo quien da vida a un mundo nuevo,
cuidando de los otros, incluso asumiendo los costos.
De hecho, decía la Madre Teresa de Calcuta,
no se puede amar si no es a costo propio.
Tenemos mucho que hacer, y debemos hacerlo juntos.
Pero, ¿cómo hacer con todo el mal que respiramos?
Gracias a Dios,
ningún sistema puede prohibir que nos abramos al bien, a la compasión,
a la capacidad de reaccionar al mal
que nace del corazón del hombre.
Ahora me dirán:
"Sí, bellas palabras,
pero yo no soy el Buen Samaritano y mucho menos la Madre Teresa de Calcuta".
Sin embargo, cada uno de nosotros es precioso;
cada uno de nosotros es irremplazable ante los ojos de Dios.
En esta noche de conflictos que estamos atravesando
cada uno de nosotros puede ser una vela iluminada
que nos recuerda que la luz prevalece sobre las tinieblas,
y no al contrario.
Para nosotros cristianos el futuro tiene nombre,
y este nombre es esperanza.
Tener esperanza no significa ser optimistas, ingenuos,
ignorantes del drama de los males de la humanidad.
La esperanza es la virtud de un corazón
que no se aferra a las sombras, que no se refugia en el pasado,
que no vive a duras penas el presente,
sino que sabe ver el mañana.
La esperanza es la puerta abierta al porvenir.
Es una semilla de vida, humilde y oculta,
que con el tiempo se transforma en un gran árbol;
es como una levadura invisible que hace levar la pasta,
que da sabor a toda la vida.
Es capaz de mucho,
porque basta solo una pequeña luz que se alimente de esperanza,
y la oscuridad ya no estará completa.
Basta un solo hombre para que haya esperanza,
y este hombre puedes ser tú.
Después otro "tú", y otro "tú",
y entonces somos "nosotros".
Y cuando hay un "nosotros",
¿comienza la esperanza?
No, ya ha comenzado con el "tú".
Cuando hay un nosotros, comienza una revolución.
El tercer y último mensaje que me gustaría compartir hoy
es sobre la revolución: la revolución de la ternura.
¿Qué es la ternura?
Es el amor que se acerca y se hace concreto.
Es un movimiento que parte del corazón
y llega a los ojos, a las orejas, a las manos.
La ternura es usar los ojos para ver al otro,
usar las orejas para sentir al otro,
para escuchar el grito de los niños,
de los pobres, de quien teme al futuro;
escuchar también el grito silencioso de nuestra casa común,
de la Tierra contaminada y enferma.
La ternura significa usar las manos y el corazón
para acariciar al otro, para cuidarlo.
La ternura es el lenguaje de los más pequeños,
de quienes necesitan del otro.
Un niño se encariña y conoce al papá y a la mamá
por las caricias, por la mirada, por la voz, por la ternura.
Me gusta escuchar
cuando el papá o la mamá hablan con su hijo pequeño,
y ellos también se hacen niños,
hablando como habla él, el niño.
Eso es la ternura: rebajarse al nivel del otro.
También Dios se rebajó en Jesús
para estar a nuestro nivel.
Este es el camino recorrido por el Buen Samaritano.
Es el camino recorrido por Jesús,
que se rebajó,
que recorrió toda la vida del hombre
con el lenguaje concreto del amor.
Sí, la ternura es el camino
que han recorrido los hombres y mujeres más valientes y fuertes.
La ternura no es debilidad, es fortaleza.
Es el camino de la solidaridad, el camino de la humildad.
Permítanme decirlo claramente:
cuanto más poderoso eres,
cuanto más tus acciones tienen un impacto sobre la gente,
mucho más humilde has de ser.
Porque si no el poder te arruina,
y tú arruinarás a los demás.
En Argentina,
se decía que el poder es como tomar ginebra en ayunas:
la cabeza te da vueltas, te embriaga, te hace perder el equilibrio
y te lleva a hacerte daño a ti mismo y a los demás,
si no lo juntas con la humildad y la ternura.
Sin embargo, con humildad y amor concreto
el poder - el más alto, el más fuerte -
se hace servicio y difunde el bien.
El futuro de la humanidad no está solo en manos de los políticos,
de los grandes líderes, de las grandes empresas.
Sí, su responsabilidad es enorme.
Pero el futuro está sobre todo en las manos de las personas
que reconocen al otro como un "tú"
y a sí mismos como parte de un "nosotros".
Necesitamos los unos a los otros.
Y por eso, por favor, recuérdenme también con ternura,
para que lleve a cabo la tarea que me ha sido encomendada
para el bien del otro, de todos.
De todos Uds., de todos nosotros.
Gracias.